[MUSIC - ROBERT ASHBRIDGE,
"GOING UP"]
Not commenting code.
Oh my god.
So when I was an
undergrad, I once
tried to explain to
one of my professors,
who was one of the
original authors of Java,
that Python was
self-documenting.
And so I didn't need to
comment my code because Python
is so easy to read.
And he just laughed at me.
He laughed for five minutes and
was like, get out of my office.
Maybe it's one indexing.
One indexing is a pretty
awful language decision
that I really
vehemently dislike.
Repetitive code.
Nobody wants to see
the same code written
1,000 times in a file.
Long code.
People reinventing the same
classes over and over again.
This is very commonplace
in the Python and PyTorch
community, that people are
reinventing the PyTorch
layers over and over again.
And nobody wants to see that.
And everyone just wants
to use the standard ones.
But for some
reason, nobody does.
Maybe it's not
really a pet peeve.
A source of misery is
debugging distributed things.
So when you have multiple
nodes working together
and something's
breaking somewhere,
debugging stack traces of
where that's happening,
and reasoning across
multiple independent servers,
and then all these race
conditions is suffering.
I really don't
like it when people
write large blocks of code
and no breakups of creating
functions and everything.
It's like, modularization
is so useful
because it helps break up little
concepts into a format that's
actually easy to
understand for people.
And also, lack of documentation.
Well, that would be too
a pet peeve of mine.
I think my biggest pet peeve
would be lack of organization.
So I guess particularly in
file layout and code structure.
So I think, yeah,
sometimes you see
either just a bunch of
different pieces of code
all in one directory.
And there's no directory layout.
Or even within a
given piece of code,
there's, yeah, just not
much rhyme or reason to
how the structure is laid out.
Sometimes, it's
just like the code--
you can clearly tell if the code
evolved as someone was thinking
and there wasn't
much restructuring.
And so, yeah, I think,
yeah, lack of organization
makes it really hard to go back
and either as a third party
understand what someone was
doing or even yourself a year
later trying to
understand your own code.
It's almost like a
different person.
Poor documentation.
[LAUGHTER]
Lack of comments and
poor documentation.
Lack of explanation.
Lack of documentation
around APIs.
And yeah, make it
easy for me, please.
[MUSIC - ROBERT ASHBRIDGE,
"GOING UP"]